[Music]
it's time the puppy Conan five
[Applause]
see handy guy
[Applause]
we look good this year why is the puppy
Andy better behaved than the real Andy
well look at me I look sad I look like
I'm depressed about something Andy's got
his puppy comb-over I look gorgeous yeah
you can you can sorta see a little bit
more a puppy Andy than you might want to
[Applause]
that's why that's why I have the desk
dandy and I doing a harangue commercial
up just lights out there well I like how
puppy Conan's like what else you good
puppy Conan's first guest is a
broadcasting legend great friend of the
show please welcome puppy Larry King
let's get him
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay Oh our musical guest musical guest
is a respected songwriter and singer
she's huge right now it's puppy see ya
let's get puppies
well that didn't work Buffy Sita puppy
Larry King outing her
yes
[Applause]
Larry Larry Kings getting mad yeah Larry
Kings wondering why am i left out our
next guest
despite her poor showing in Monday's
Iowa caucus is still campaigning please
welcome puppey Carly Fiorina
[Applause]
wait a minute that's a good match
[Applause]
Larry King bikes it look at Larry King
is like check out my ass Larry King our
next guest our next gal guy
[Applause]
our next guest was just recaptured by
the Miskin police after tunneling out of
prison please welcome with his tunneled
puppy El Chapo
[Applause]
if we going to come out woody come out
he's one of my favorite one please
please please come out I love you
[Applause]
our final guest is fresh off his
second-place finish in Iowa's Republican
caucus
please welcome puppey Donald Trump you
got it
[Applause]
all right work here is done